There's no denying that human babies are cute,...
...but even other species tend to have adorable infants.
So, why has science conditioned us to find babies so precious?
Is there something specific that triggers our urge to hold and squeeze them?
Interestingly, studies have found...
...that macaque monkeys pay little attention to newborn faces,...
...leading researchers to believe that the "cute feeling" may be an entirely human trait.
Unlike many other species,...
...once born, human babies are completely dependent on their parents for survival.
As a result, humans have adapted to find certain traits...
...aesthetically pleasing and downright adorable...
...in an effort to increase interaction, care and protection from parents.
This, in turn, enhances offspring survival and perpetuates our species.